I love you know I mentioned that we love
you King Ben but sometimes we wonder if
you truly know what mal is all about
you guys are so different after all we
know that opposites attract but we can't
help but think that a certain pirate
would be a better match for the daughter
of Maleficent as it turns out then
there's someone even more perfect for
you out there but don't worry it's not
Audrey no offense buddy bear you're just
too trusting
mal and Ben are all set to become the
king and queen of auradon but some
descendants fans would rather see mal
tie the knot with Harry hook in this
video we explain why mal and Harry are
the real deal but if mal and Harry get
together who will then end up with keep
watching to find out there's no use
fighting it mal and Ben were made for
each other
or at least that's what the Disney
Channel wants us to think
although Malin Ben our cannon many fans
of The Descendants franchise would
rather see mal with someone else
some fans truly believe that Harry hook
is the perfect match for mal and they
have some pretty convincing arguments
too but before we tell you why mal and
Harry are a match made in heaven let's
start right into why Malin Ben aren't
exactly endgame material then and mal
come from opposite sides of the track
and while opposites usually attract some
people are just too different
sure mal and then both have leadership
skills in the bag and they know what
it's like for their parents to have high
expectations of them but then always
wanted the life his parents set out for
him he had a happy childhood everything
was given to him on a silver platter
whereas mal had to fight for scraps Ben
can only imagine what life on the aisle
was like and somewhere deep down Val
might resent him for it Malin Ben had a
lot of chemistry in the first
Descendants film especially when they
first met but by the time descendants 2
& 3 came along their chemistry had died
down drastically on top of that Ben's
love for mal became questionable he got
upset with her for using magic on him in
descendants - and cast aside his
long-term girlfriend Audrey without so
much as an explanation let alone an
apology despite all of this
as a stand-up guy who fights for change
and equality I choose to be a king who
moves forward it's time for forgiveness
but he's an Oregon kid who doesn't
always understand what mouths motives
are or where she's coming from a few
months after mal chose to return to the
Isle of the Lost
Ben proposed to her and she accepted
cementing her into a lifelong role at
only 17 years old and what we have no
doubt that Ben and mal will live out
their happily ever after fans can't help
but wonder if mal would be happier with
the VK by her side and according to them
Harry Hook is the ideal candidate in
descendants to mal comes face to face
with Harry in the curl up and die salon
and their chemistry is off the charts
mal is totally flirting with Harry and
he singing offer every word at this
point in the sequel mal and Ben are
broken up and it looks like mal is
already ready to move on obviously
nothing happens between them but this
scene had fans shipping Harry and mal in
no time Harry and mal are compatible in
a lot of ways they're both nice people
who have had to act evil to make their
parents proud mal bullied her friends
and ruled over the V case to make
Maleficent happy and Harry became a
pirate just like his dad Captain Hook
Harry even went as far as to wear a fake
hook to continue his father's legacy but
despite their evil tendencies mal and
Harry want to do what's right
Harry helped the vks and ak's save
auradon in descendants three but he
acted like it was no big deal
Harry talks a big game but deep down he
just wants to be accepted in the same
way mal does but what makes the mal and
Harry Shep all the more convincing is
that actors dubbed Cameron and Thomas
Doherty are dating in real life and
they're totally endgame Dov and Thomas
confirmed their relationship in 2017
which explained why they had so much
on-screen chemistry and funny enough
fans weren't the only one shipping mal
in Harry because dub and Thomas were
equally as obsessed with the couple so
much so that they went as far as to him
then
entire backstory for their characters
according to Kenny Ortega Dov and Thomas
Malin Harry used today on the aisle
their backstory places Harry and mal as
childhood friends who quickly fell in
love
they even got matching hook tattoos but
when things went sour with Ouma mal
JumpShip and broke Harry's heart
suddenly their intense chemistry makes a
whole lot of sense Harry was just
reacting to seeing his ex-girlfriend for
the first time in months
evidently davon Thomas's backstory
sounds a lot like fan fiction but fans
are digging it anyway but wait a second
if mal and Harry are endgame who is been
destined to be with well we totally see
him with what's your name Kumud was it
just a sordid Ouma and Ben have some
serious chemistry in descendants - what
do you guys think are Mallon been
perfect for each other
or are they about to marry the wrong
people sound off in the comments and
that's a wrap
thanks for watching and don't forget to
Like and subscribe we'll catch you next
time on the things
[Music]
you